this video is sponsored by the
supporters at my patreon page
check it out see the reward tiers
available and help keep this whole thing
going
you know speaking as a 90s kid i do
think my life would have been greatly
improved by the presence of time
traveled and lesbians
[Music]
so folks something a little different
this time i sat down and had a
conversation with
savvy leicester who has the youtube
channel savvy rights books which is a
great channel you should check it out
and she recently released her book
90s kids and i having recently released
my own book it seemed nicely
serendipitous for us to sit down and
talk to each other about
our various recently published works so
we're going to talk about
what's in the book her thought process
and going into it her motivations how
she approached the material and also a
little bit at the end
as to what the experience was like for
her working with
a publisher granted a small publisher
for the first time after having done
basically self-publishing up to this
point so
if you have an interest in the types of
fiction that this is this sort of
uh romance nostalgia sci-fi kind of
story or if you just want to find out
more about the writing process
and the publishing process i think you
should check this video out and i hope
you enjoy it
let's get to it so savvy thank you so
much for
taking the time to talk to me this is
really exciting
yeah thank you so much for having me on
your channel this is really exciting
because i've loved your channel for such
a long time
thanks so much i love what you do as as
well and i
i i feel almost like a certain bit of
kindred spirits because
like that there are things about your
channel that like
you wouldn't expect those on the same
site like the between
the business stuff and then the nti mlm
stuff and then the actual
you know reviews of books i'm looking at
that going
she didn't specialize all that much
either neither do i okay
my channel is so chaotic i'm always
worried like like it's
it's a book review channel but it's a
business ethics commentary channel
but it's uh it's a lot of things and
then now this
past month i'm like well actually now
it's an lgbt commentary channel for now
and then we'll
go back to book reviews so it's all
about i mean
last month was pride month so that was
incredibly fitting
yeah so um your new book
90s kid
oh oh there it is folks
so i'm well first of all do you want to
give
sort of the elevator pitch on it the
elevator the short elevator pitch is
it's lesbian back to the future
love it on principle already um
do you want to give a slightly more
detailed version absolutely yes so it's
it's a book um
about the way that the world has evolved
a little bit over the past
30-ish years it's about two girls one
was born in 1990 and one was born in
1999 so opposite ends of the 90s
and one is a teenager in 2006 when
there's
myspace and emo music in that whole
world and one's a teenager in 2015 where
she's
on tumblr and trying to avoid everyone
trying to get her to get on dating apps
because she doesn't like men
and things like that there's two
different uh two different eras
both of them go to the dmv to take their
driving test
and at the dmv they've been secretly
developing a time portal this whole time
so they both get in a
time travel accident and get sent back
to 1989
where they're both 16 years old where
they meet each other
fall in love and run from government
officials trying to keep them contained
at the dmv so they won't cause a time
paradox
that's just that description is a ride
and it's a ride i'm loving
thank you it's a lot of like pop culture
references everywhere and stuff like
that
so i i don't want to be so crassus to
just flat out ask your age but i am
curious as to your own
sort of relationship to the 90s and that
era you can ask my age i'm 28.
um and uh yeah so the i was born in 92
so i i didn't i guess i was a child
for the night for the entire 90s um but
i i have a pretty good memory which is a
double-edged sword i used to
have like a like a photographic memory
before i started
ocd medication but that's a completely
different story but i
used to have a very photographic memory
which is good because it's like
i have so many strong and vivid memories
of different time periods even if
i was very young during them or didn't
you know didn't seem to perceive them as
an adult or anything
but at the same time it's like well now
all my childhood trauma is never going
away it's
there i don't get to forget any of that
um
even if i'm like two years old you know
so that's like uh
this is a double-edged sword however um
i did um
i think the pop culture of the night
like the 90s was the worst for me like
it was a terrible decade for me in my
life had a terrible time but the pop
culture was awesome i love the music i
love the tv shows and the movies and all
of that
um growing up and being a teenager in
the early to mid 2000s i was really
into 80s nostalgia which i feel like
is everyone has like nostalgia for like
20 years before the time they're
currently in so
that's where i was at that time i was so
into like 80s music
and like dressing like i was like an 80s
pop star and things like that i was
always like the quirky girl
so that was uh that was my teenage years
so i got so
invested in 80s pop culture and 90s pop
culture growing up that i was like
i gotta put all this into a book
especially because then once i went to
college i started getting nostalgic for
like the 2003-2004 era pop culture
and i was like man i need to like put on
my eyeliner and listen to green day
and all of that so i was i was very
excited to just explore the
nuances of all of that and you know
there were people like
people who were much older than me would
ask like is a teenager in 2006 and 2015
gonna be that different and i was like
yes they are gonna be that different i
promise i will i will make it clear
so this might seem like an odd question
but
i'll explain a second do you have older
siblings no
okay that i find that interesting and
here's why so like
i was born similar to you but in the 80s
i was born in 82.
oh cool and uh and as a result like
my actual memory of the 80s and 80s pop
culture especially
it's very narrow and it's very child
focused like i remember he-man and
thundercats and and the real
ghostbusters cartoon but
i don't i have no nostalgic memories for
mtv or what was on the radio or anything
like that
and the reason that i asked is like
there are a lot of people my age
who have stronger 80s nostalgia but i
tend to find that they usually have
older siblings who were filtering that
down to them
so that at a younger age they were still
experiencing the pop culture
of people older than they are so i i had
i couldn't help but wonder if that had
been the case for you and it's
interesting that it wasn't
no i think it's just that i like i've
always been a nostalgic
person and i've always like been like
really interested in the past but not
necessarily in like the history of it
but more like the pop culture of the
past
so i've always just like sought it out
intentionally
like when i was in high school i would
like make 80s mixtapes where i would
find like greatest hits of the adcds and
make
burn cds of them and things like that so
i would like look for it on purpose
because i always thought it was cool
that is very good
so that there seem to be like three main
components to the story that we've got
here there
is um a lesbian romance
there is time travel there is 90s
nostalgia
i'm kind of curious as to what the the
chicken and the egg on that was
what what was the one where you started
from and at what point did the
others get integrated um okay so
i think i want to say i think the time
travel was where it started from
because it's the i first started mapping
out this novel after i had a dream that
i had
time traveled into the 80s and while in
the 80s i met a cute girl and we fell in
love but we had to go back to different
time periods afterwards
and then i was like that could be
actually an interesting novel when i
woke up
so i started like writing down ideas for
that and then
i combined it with this component of i
always used to make this really stupid
joke so just like let this be a lesson
to everyone your stupid jokes can get
incorporated into a novel if you want
i always make the stupid joke because
you know in the city i don't i don't
have a car i've never owned a car
um but i did used to have a driver's
license but i don't use it because i
don't have a car
so i let my driver's license expire and
then
i would go to a bar and they'd be like
your id is expired and i'd be like
literally why do you care it was
always valid it was never fake so like
it says that i was
over 21. so if i was over 21 when it was
valid how could i be under 21 now you
can't get younger
and then i was like unless the dmv is
developing time travel
and that's why it's that's why they
they have to update your license so much
because theoretically
they're they're the ones regulating
whether or not you know
so i was like what if that's it and
people are like sami this is the
stupidest joke of all time just like go
get your license updated and i refused
and so now i just take my passport to
the bar and
instead i wrote a novel where the dmv
actually developed time travel
i honestly i that was on my list of
things to ask was
how the dmv got roped into this and
that is a better explanation than i
could have possibly hoped for
it came from and my publisher when i
when she was doing the final edit she
was like
sev you never actually explained why the
dmv developed time travel in the first
place so i'll just read the little
explanation from this book
because um
because she was like i was like they
just she's like why why did they develop
it in the universe though
so there's a part where she first goes
back in time is asking the dmv official
why did you develop time travel at the
dmv and he stares and says that he
stared at her
and seemed confused as if she just asked
him the most obvious question in the
world
we're the department motor the
department of motor vehicles we handle
all forms of travel would you rather the
irs handle it instead
that's that's why time travels developed
at the dmv
i love like that is that is one of my
favorite kinds of explanations for
especially sci-fi nonsense
yeah there's a lot of sci-fi nonsense in
this i
i love explanations that are basically
one
line borderline dismissive explanation
that that basically says signals to the
to the reader like
look there is an explanation but this is
all you need in order to deal with what
we're doing
in life we don't understand everything
about everything anyway the main
characters don't have to understand so
like
there'd be drafts and iterations we'd go
through the editing process or it's like
do we want to explain more the mechanics
of the time travel here and we would and
then we'd be like oh but then that
raises a million other questions and
we'd be like
what if we just didn't like time travel
happens you know
i mean in fiction it doesn't happen in
real life because it doesn't make sense
for it to happen in real life
so yeah we just kind of let it left it
up to the reader's imagination in a lot
of ways
so like as a doctor who fan and as a fan
of time travel stories i would be
uh remiss not to ask this how did you
settle on what your time travel rules
were going to be
because there's a lot of options as far
as that goes
the way well i don't want to give it
away but there's a plus you don't yeah
you don't have to say what there because
i i
it's not uncommon for the exact nature
of the time travel rules to be
a spoiler later on yeah but i'm just
curious as to like
how you uh you came to settle on
whatever ones you did
so i've been writing this book for so
long that i'm like wondering if i can
even i've been
working on this for like three years um
and so let me see if i can even remember
how i settled on what they were
i think i started with making them
similar to the rules and back to the
future
and then making them completely
different from them as a plot twist
like that's kind of but i won't say in
what specific ways because i don't want
to spoil big plot things
but yeah i started my inspiration with
that and then since one of the main
characters in the book is really into
sci-fi
she keeps trying to figure out what's
going on by applying the rules from back
to the future and from star trek and
from fictional sci-fi that she likes
try to apply those rules to see if that
could help them figure out what's going
on
and in the end it doesn't but at least
it's a starting point for these two
teenagers in this weird situation
yeah now i i like that as an approach
because i think there's there's
often a temptation in science fiction
that isn't
science fantasy so like yes you don't
get to say with star wars but
for aside from that subgenre i think
it's very common for science fiction
stories especially books because they
have space to do it to over explain
yeah to the point that i find myself
going no i got it you can
you can stop explaining no i got it i
gotta i got enough
to get the story you can stop
um but like to a certain extent i get it
because there is a at least a sliver of
a sci-fi audience that wants
all those details but i i i personally
tend to appreciate a
more streamlined approach yeah because i
really wanted this book to focus on
um one the characters relationship the
uh the characters each having their own
arc you know one character being very
introverted and having to learn to come
out of her shell but still maintaining
her introverted personality
but learning to you know trust people
more and then the other character who's
obsessed with nostalgia for the past
because she's
living in fear of the future and having
to learn to understand that there's an
acceptance that time is going to move
forward in life
so i wanted to focus in a little more on
those arcs than on like
the mechanics of the time travel or
those things but i wanted it to make
enough sense that readers weren't going
to be like wait what
so i think i struck that balance um i've
gotten a few goodreads reviews that says
i did a good job striking that balance
so i'm feeling confident now
um but yeah that's because i wanted to
kind of keep the focus there
that that's always that's always like
early in the release of a books
like that's that's the that's the thing
that hangs over your head like
i tried to have it do this and hopefully
exactly
yes you're stuck with that until more
feedback comes
in yep now i i am also curious
in terms of what you feel the target
audience is
for this particular book so two target
audiences one would be current teenagers
because it's a young adult novel and the
second would be
adults who love to read y a so this book
was almost
i mean it was definitely written for the
y audience but it was almost even more
so written for the adults who love y a
audience because you know there's like a
whole
a whole category of adults who love
young adult i'm one of them
a lot of people in their late 20s to mid
30s and even older who are like when's
the next y-a novel coming out when am i
gonna get this book from
john green or from rainbow rowell or
whoever they're just like chomping at
the bit for those i am too i get it
so i thought that would be cool to have
a y a novel that represented the time
periods of like
current mid-tier millennials i said
mid-tier i meant like mid
rate i didn't mean i'm not talking about
the quality i'm talking about like
the year you were born but i i wanted to
have something that would represent that
era
of like oh here's a teenager life when
the world was entrenched in the internet
but it was still pre-social media and we
barely had myspace and like people
having a cell phone when you were a cool
kid and things like that
versus like seeing you know a time
period where teenagers now who are kind
of on that millennial and generation z
cusp
uh to represent them as well but then
we're also seeing teens on
tick tock nowadays being nostalgic for
like
oh my god i wish i could have been
growing up when they were listening to
misery business and stuff like that and
i'm like
why are you nostalgic for i'm not even
30 and you're already nostalgic for my
teenager life
so i guess it could really fit for that
teen audience as well so i think those
are kind of the main
demographics yeah that because that was
something i found myself thinking about
like well
given the age of the protagonists i have
to assume there's a y a audience as a
target
but then like would they have nostalgia
for the 90s and like i
and i wasn't necessarily thinking it
wouldn't work but it made me want to
want to pick your brain on that a little
bit so yeah that's the idea is that it's
a it's a crossover for those like
the millennial gen x adults who still
love to read why a and never want to
give it up
and also the current teenagers
who are nostalgic for
the past they didn't get to live which i
was as a teenager as well so that's kind
of
the two target audiences of it hopefully
it resonates with both of those groups
so it sounded like wanting to tell a a
queer love story was was one of was part
of your initial
impetus to that did you have any
did you have either influences on how
you wanted to do that or did you have a
list of be sure i don't do this
oh yeah um so when it came to like the
queer element of it there was
the main thing i wanted to show was that
like you can have
three time periods that are very close
together in
the grand scheme of the universe but are
so
vastly different when it comes to like
mainstream acceptance of queer culture
like you can look at 1989 right and
during that time when they're stuck back
there
they're seeing like protests going on
regarding like a lack of health care for
the hiv pandemic because that was a huge
issue at that time then they're in 2005
and it's like
well do we support same-sex marriage
that's kind of a left-wing progressive
thing to think versus like now that's
the very baseline for not being an
[ __ ] like
you that's not regressive that's like
the minimum that's less than the minimum
and now there's like while we're still
have a long way to go with in
in terms of a lot of things things have
improved already so much within the past
10 15 years that we're now seeing more
of like a mainstream
pop culture narrative around this and
that's why we have
you know one character who's really into
the like tumblr fan fiction culture
who's into like writing queer fan
fiction online and her sister's like are
you gay and she's like
no i'm not gay but she's gay spoiler
she's gay
uh self-insert per chance oh no see
neither of these are self-inserts
although i will say i definitely relate
a lot to both of the
main characters uh the other thing i
wanted to show was um
just kind of the specifically this i
guess is done in a more subtle way but
specifically the way that like
the bisexual and asexual acceptance has
increased a lot over between the 2000s
and the 2010s like there's no question
so we can see that evolving as well
because
the one main character nicole is a
lesbian but she's also kind of asexual
coded
in that she might be somewhere on the
asexual spectrum
and bex is definitively bisexual but
doesn't
know it right away because in 2006 a lot
of people were kind of like
well if you're gay then that's you know
i guess you
you could get married to someone if you
have to do that
like you know as opposed to like her
being like well she
is attracted to multiple genders and
that is okay but a lot of people don't
understand or accept it
you see kind of the contrast where
nicole's in 2015 and her
best friend is actually bisexual and
it's like not even treated as a
a bad thing or a a weird thing at all
that's just kind of a thing she knows
about him and like
so it just kind of shows a progression
there and how
those those time periods treat it
differently
and how it's kind of i guess this is
where like the star trek influence comes
in where it's like
you want to look at an optimistic view
of the future so the whole
the whole main theme throughout it is
like the world gets better as things go
on it might not seem like things are
okay right now and there might be a lot
of things that are
difficult and you have to work on and
that society really needs to fix
but overall it's going to continue to
improve because history has shown that
to be the progress
that and teenagers from every time
period are all the same
and the dmv always sucks
[Laughter]
so it am i correct in this this is is
this the first time you've worked with
the publisher as opposed to
self-publishing
yeah yeah i mean i've worked in the past
i worked with like a
indie publisher like more like a
self-publishing service type of thing
where like i retained the rights and
paid someone for self-publishing
services on a small scale i've done
that before but this is the first time
i've worked with a publisher in the
traditional kind of way where like yeah
they cover all the costs and i get the
royalty payment yeah
so was there um other than
just sort of um them covering the cost
were there any
significant differences of just the
process of
getting the book ready for a publication
or actually having it published that uh
you felt were
were notable versus having done
self-published or
closed to self-published previously yeah
i i think that well one thing i really
liked was uh getting connected with
industry professionals without having to
connect myself to people you know in the
past like
if i wanted to you know hire someone for
a service you know i'm
when i'm self-publishing it's i'm in the
entrepreneurial role there i have to
find everyone versus like
this cover like this i'm in love with
this cover i'm trying to figure out
where to get it tattooed on me because i
love this cover so much
um and this cover was designed by
i did an interview with him on my
youtube channel his name's eric evanson
who was the artist who did the cover and
he was actually
an artist for one of the officially
licensed back to the future comics
so it was really it's really cool i was
just fangirling
like out the ass dude i was going crazy
about how much
i was like going crazy about how excited
i was to work with him
and his work just turned out so
beautiful and it was like my publisher
um she had started a books division
after she'd been publishing magazines
for
13 years so she had known him from
having he had done art for a magazine
she worked on and things like that so
she was able to make that connection
and then the layout artist for the book
was the same as the layout artist my
publisher uses for the magazines that
she publishes and things like that
so it was interesting to get connected
with people who are going to do a
professional job without having to be
the one to
hire an interview and look at work
samples and discuss
rates and said someone else handled that
end of it for me um
but i will say that working with a small
press was really nice because
as opposed to having an agent and having
a
big corporation publisher i definitely
felt like i was
included in every single part of the
process i was in every single cover
design meeting i
reviewed the layouts all of that which i
guess is more work for me but is also
more creative input for me
so i thought that it was just a really
collaborative process or kind of got the
best of every
world in that sense that that sounds
like it went really well for you
that's great yeah i i had a great time i
would definitely work with the small
press again
especially because you know on my
channel on on youtube i'm always talking
about
how i'm so passionate about women owning
small businesses and things like that so
to have my first traditional publishing
experience to be with a woman-owned
small
press was just kind of perfect i'm like
this is great i love it so
i was really happy that's fantastic
so um i'm going to have links uh in the
description
to for people to be able to check out
your book we'll put
both the amazon and the goodreads links
uh in there
um so that people can check those out
and hopefully i
i suspect that there's definitely going
to be a chunk of my audience who will
probably find
something to like in this so i hope so i
i'm just
i'm so happy about this book my joy for
this is like through the roof i've been
having such a
good time since this came out so i
really appreciate being able to talk
about it on your channel
um and getting to just kind of talk with
you one on one it's been really nice
it has been so thank you so much for
coming on absolutely
gonna thank savvy once more for taking
the time to speak with me i had a lot of
fun doing this it's a little different
than what i normally do and don't expect
this to become a
regular feature or anything but i had a
lot of fun with this conversation i hope
you did as well or that you found it in
lightning
check out her channel check out the
links related to her book
maybe buy it if it sounded interesting
to you or check out other people's
reviews if you
want to get even a little more sense
than you might have gotten from this
video on it
also um later next week and i'll put a
link in my
community tabs and i'll pin it in a
comment once it's available
there will be a video of savvy
interviewing me about my own book over
on her channel so check that out when
that goes live
in any case whatever your thoughts are
on anything she and i talked about drop
something down the comments and let's
talk about it
thank you so much for your support and
if you're just able to drop
the usual like share subscribe helps me
out greatly no
pressure though end of the day you're
the council
i'm just running the meetings so until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]